hello everybody the charity livestream
is going on right now and I'm here with
Wade say hi Wade all right that's enough
way thank you guys so much for helping
us support the Cincinnati Children's
Hospital we're trying to raise twenty
five thousand dollars and a hundred
percent of the proceeds go directly to
the hospital we got a donation page set
up just for this specific purpose it's
secure donation so that they all I don't
touch a cent of it they go straight to
the charity I will be donating myself
and we are live streaming right now so
click the link in the description below
all right click the link in the
description below all the necessary
information is down there the link for
the livestream channel the link for the
page to Cincinnati Children's Hospital
if you can't make it to the live stream
please click the link for the donation
page yourself and donate now donate
whatever you can dig deep just help out
this is a great cause and also help
share around um with your friends and
family to try to get are you doing I
merely I'll try to add symbolism today
you're throwing gang signs we're raising
money for the children be set not be
that fu in French ok so anyway this is
for the children by the way that is
that's what it is we we don't think so
oh okay anyway so this has gone awry but
we are live right now so if you like
this sort of entertainment you'll find
this prop please click the link for the
children children so anyway thank you
all so much we hope to see you there
it's gonna be fun time we've got lots of
games lined up so we'll see you there by
not gone yet I got that